SPEAKER: In our last episode,
we covered the best practices
for deploying and using cloud
operations in an enterprise
environment.
But we still left some
questions unanswered.
How should you
monitor your services?
How should you deal with alerts?
And what about managing costs?
Today, we'll look
at best practices
that you can use to get the most
value out of cloud monitoring.
Welcome to Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
Just like last time,
let's first figure out
why monitoring is
important at all.
What are we trying to achieve
when we use cloud monitoring?
We're after three main
objectives in parallel.
Our first objective is
to keep our users happy.
That means we need to know
whether our service is
meeting their needs.
And the best way to do that
is through well-defined SLOs
and error budgets,
and alerts that
let us know when our service
is burning error budget.
Our second objective is to be
able to quickly and effectively
respond when those
alerts do fire.
This means having enough data
about the state of our service
to be able to triage incidents,
identify effective mitigations,
and accurately confirm
the effectiveness
of those mitigations.
Our final goal is to do the
first two while managing
the associated costs.
Now that we've covered the
whys, let's turn to the hows.
We'll start by talking
about what to monitor.
From there, we'll get into
how to best manage alerts.
And finally, we'll
cover cost management
for cloud monitoring.
Let's get into it.
Let's start by talking about
the obvious first question.
What should you be monitoring?
For the answer, we
can turn to chapter 6
of the "Site Reliability
Engineering" book on monitoring
distributed systems.
Fundamentally, the
objective of monitoring
is to answer two questions.
The first one is
all about symptoms.
What are our users experiencing,
and is that experience
in any way less than ideal?
The second question
is all about causes.
What's causing the
symptoms we've identified?
That cause may be
direct or intermediate,
but it's how we
start to determine
how to restore user experience
back to the desired state
if it's degraded in some way.
We answer the first question by
clearly defining our service,
identifying good service
level indicators, or SLIs
that tell us, as
accurately as possible,
how well our service is able to
meet our users' expectations,
and defining good service
level objectives, or SLOs, that
set a target that our
SLIs have to meet.
We've covered defining
services, SLIs, and SLOs
in cloud monitoring
extensively in the series,
but it's always worth
revisiting these topics.
The first thing to answer to
the question of what should we
monitor is, how
well is your service
meeting the needs of your users
as expressed by good SLOs?
The next thing to make sure
you're monitoring covers
is what the "SRE" book refers
to as the golden signals.
Traffic is essentially
a measure of how much
user activity the service
is responding to, usually
as a count of incoming requests
for user-facing services
or data elements
for data pipelines.
Error rate is a measure of
what percentage of the time
the user activity
is not successful,
which, of course, depends on the
service and user expectations.
Latency is a measure of
how long the service takes
to service a request.
And finally,
saturation is a measure
of how much of the
available capacity
the service is using
at a given time.
A great way to
ensure that you have
easy access to these signals
is to create a dashboard
like this.
It shows the four golden signals
for a given service at once.
It makes it easy to correlate,
for example, increases
in inbound traffic to latency
degradations or increased
capacity requirements.
You could automate the
creation of dashboards
like this for your services.
We'll link to some examples
in the episode notes.
Finally, you may need to
augment your monitoring
with custom telemetry to capture
service-specific information.
We covered doing this
in a previous episode.
Review that for an introduction
to instrumenting your services
with OpenCensus and Prometheus.
So that takes care of
the first question,
what you should be monitoring.
We've just covered SLOs, golden
signals, and custom telemetry,
which brings us to alerting.
How should you configure alerts?
What should you alert on?
And how should you
respond to alerts?
Let's take a look.
Let's again return to the
monitoring chapter of the "SRE"
book.
These four criteria
should be applied
to alerts that go to pagers.
Every time the
pager goes off, we
should be able to react
with a sense of urgency.
But we can only react
with a sense of urgency
a few times a day before
we become fatigued.
Every page should be actionable.
Every page response should
require intelligence.
If a page merits only
a robotic response,
it shouldn't be a page.
And ideally, pages alert
us about a novel problem
or an event that hasn't
been seen before.
That means we need
to take action
to prevent pages from
reoccurring once we've
mitigated the
triggering condition
and, hopefully,
identified the root cause.
Alerts that don't meet these
criteria should not be pages.
Alerts that aren't actionable
are of no use at all.
Alerts that require
human intervention
but that aren't urgent should
be filed as tickets instead.
Cloud monitoring supports
multiple notification channels.
And this allows you to
set up alert delivery that
meets your needs.
For example, you could use
email or PagerDuty delivery
to trigger pagers.
Then configure a webhook
or Pub/Sub integration
to file tickets for
non-urgent alerts.
You can also automate the
management of your alerts
by using an automation
tool like Terraform.
This helps to ensure consistency
and avoids human errors
in alert configuration.
Finally, it's
important to understand
the tools you have available
to capture and optimize
your monitoring costs.
Let's have a look at those now.
First, it's important
to understand
how you incur monitoring costs.
Platform metrics emitted
by Google Cloud Services
are always free.
You are charged
for other metrics,
such as custom metrics or
those written by Istio,
based on storage volume.
Refer to the Pricing
page for the latest
version of this information.
The Monitoring Settings page
shows you exactly how much data
you are ingesting for each
project in your metrics scope.
You can measure your usage
by using billing reports
and filtering them to just
the monitoring service
to see exactly how much
monitoring charges you
are incurring in your project.
You can even figure
out exactly how much
data is being ingested
by each custom metric
by creating a chart and using
the Metric Bytes Ingested
metric.
These tools do a
great job of helping
you understand the sources
of monitoring costs.
But what can you do
to optimize those?
Let's have a look.
The way that you use
labels for cloud components
might impact the
volume of time series
that are generated for your
metrics and monitoring.
For example, you can use
labels to appropriately
report metrics to cost
centers on your bill
and to signify whether specific
environments are production
or development.
Adding these labels means
that additional time series
are generated in monitoring.
You can calculate the total
number of times series
by multiplying the
cardinality of all labels.
For example, if there
are 11 cost center
values and 5
environment values, that
means 55 time series
are generated.
This is why the way that
you add labels might
add significant metric
volume, and, therefore,
increase the cost.
We recommend carefully
limiting the number of labels
and avoiding label values
with high cardinality.
Metrics sent from
the Cloud Ops Agent
are another source
of monitoring costs.
The agent collects
app and system metrics
from common third-party apps
and additional VM-level metrics.
If you don't need
them for certain VMs,
you can reduce the volume by
not sending these metrics.
You can also reduce
the metric values
by reducing the number of
VMs that use the agent.
Custom metrics are
chargeable metrics
created by using the
monitoring API or integrations
like OpenCensus to
monitor any metrics that
are user instruments.
The more services that you
instrument to send metrics,
the more custom monitoring
metrics are generated.
If you want to reduce
metric volumes,
you can reduce the number
of custom monitoring metrics
that your services send.
Thanks for joining me today.
We've covered best practices
for setting up and using
cloud monitoring,
including what to monitor,
how to manage alerts, and how to
optimize your monitoring costs.
I hope these recommendations
help you keep your users happy.
In our next episode, we'll
tackle best practices
for using cloud logging.
Thanks so much for
watching today.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
See you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]